having gone four minutes well I
certainly hope you've learned your
lesson
for God's sake make up your mind hey
youtubers it's Charlie since we've all
had a chance to see Sherlock series 3
it's time to start talking about series
4 so what I'm gonna do is my top 10
predictions with as much evidence for
each one as possible before we get
started though I just got some really
good news and since I'm so happy I'm
giving away one copy of the series 3 DVD
to five random subscribers in the
comments all you have to do is leave a
comment I will be doing a Q&A video for
these series 4 predictions so if you
have any questions that you want me to
include in that just you know write them
in the comments those also be your
entries for the giveaway - careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen any of the
episodes yet because we will be talking
about specific plot points but let's get
started the east wind is here number 10
watson baby Mary Morstan was super
pregnant during the final moments of his
last vow
so if series 4 picks up directly after
that she's still going to have a baby in
one of those episodes I think we can all
imagine that at some point the life of
that baby will be threatened by the
villain and Sherlock's last vow will
continue to be a big theme raise your
hand if you think that Sherlock really
could be a girl's name or write your
favorite Watson baby name in the
comments number 9 Sherlock running
around with that Watson baby will break
the Internet I'm talking about tumblr
specifically but Benedict Cumberbatch
was the most reblogged person on tumblr
last year so imagine what will happen
when he starts clueing for looks with a
baby that doesn't necessarily mean that
the baby will be born during series 4
but we can assume that the baby will be
a big part of the plot regardless Baker
Street babies is totally gonna be a
thing next year I guess you could also
considered a shout-out to the Baker
Street babes - they have an awesome
Sherlock podcast number 8
Billy Wiggins will totally be back he
even called himself Sherlock's protege
when he started making deductions in
Molly's lab I actually wondered if there
was going to be a connection between
drug addiction and savants or if he was
just naturally gifted like Sherlock
either way in the Canon the Billy and
the Wiggins characters were both really
important so regardless of which stories
they adapt he'll definitely be there
during his last vow he kind of took the
collective role of the homeless network
and the Baker Street Irregulars
depending on how you look at them so I'm
also wondering if he's going to start
running Sherlock's homeless Network -
number seven even more Mycroft the
season dealt a lot with Sherlock's
family but I don't expect Benedict
Cumberbatch's parents to
turn and even if they do have cameos
they will be a lot more like empty
hearse than his last Val the Sherlock
and Mycroft's scenes are so popular in
the fandom though and the microf
character is so well developed then I
think they'll continue to be heavily
featured on screen together a big part
of their relationship that was new to
series 3 was actually their childhood
learning about things like red beard and
actually seeing young Sherlock played by
Stephen moppets real-life son the next
logical step would be to feature
flashbacks to a teenage Sherlock and
Mycroft in the Canon Mycroft is about
seven years older so it would really be
like teenage Sherlock and Mycroft at
university quick sidenote though if you
haven't seen it young Sherlock Holmes
was an 80s movie that depicted Sherlock
during those university years the actor
that played him Nicholas Rowe is
actually on da Vinci's demons right now
number six Mary will be a much bigger
part of the action in his last vow we
found out that she was an elite assassin
and a Deadshot so there's no way series
four isn't going to invoke those skills
especially since she's a mother now at
this point she's kind of like uma
Thurman in Kill Bill someone will
probably try to harm or steal her baby
and Sherlock and John will have to stop
her from trying to kill everyone
responsible I totally can't wait to see
ninja Mary fight scenes someone actually
asked me if we'd ever get to see a
Sherlock fight scene but we kind of
already did during scandal the next
logical step would be a merry fight
scene we've really only seen her use her
sharpshooter skills
number five Sherlock will still be a
murderer I don't think the series will
backtrack on Sherlock killing Magnussen
it was a big part of his last vow and
taking that away from him would kind of
undo the sincerity of that promise
Mycroft's comment about learning your
lesson is also a tip-off that there
won't be any major consequences to
Sherlock that we haven't already seen I
think the government was satisfied with
Mycroft solution and the series for
villain will probably negate any further
concerns that they might have number
four the stories this is a bit of a
problem because they've already done
most of conan doyle's best-known stories
each season has featured one of his four
novels and they've already done studying
Scarlett Hound of Baskerville and sine
of four so the next logical step is to
do valley of fear it actually features
the first chronological appearance of
Moriarty in the candidate it actually
takes place before Reichenbach Fall
but if Moriarty is back then this story
would make the most sense other stories
they could do are lady Frances CARFAX
dying detective or even the red-headed
league number three
a return to proper form Steven Moffat
said that as Sherlock gets more
emotional he becomes a less brilliant in
the final moments of his last vow kind
of imply that he's returning to form
even if the high-functioning sociopath
line is unreliable narration he's
definitely not a sociopath in my own
mind palace the best Sherlock Holmes
stories are always like chess games very
calculated very precise so I don't think
we'll see another episode like sine of
three with Sherlock dancing his way two
clues you know stoned and drunk
number two the final solution what
better way to snap Sherlock back into
form than a doomsday scenario set in
motion by the one true Moriarty notice I
said the one true Moriarty in Canon
Moriarty is every bit as clever Sherlock
and if Sherlock and Mycroft were one
step ahead of Moriarty during
Reichenbach Fall then wouldn't it stand
to reason that Moriarty would have his
own 13 different scenarios regardless of
who the villain is I think that the
post-credits scene is the signal that a
doomsday scenario has been set in motion
like a last will and testament and my
number one prediction Moriarty is really
dead and that clip we saw was being used
by another villain rule number one the
doctor always lies in the world to
Sherlock different characters take on
the role of the doctor so to speak and
in this case the Batman in the Box is
Moriarty inside your television with so
many other villains to explore it
doesn't make a lot of sense for Moffat
and Gaydos to retread old territory but
just to be clear I definitely think that
Andrew Scott will be a part of series
four just not in the way you hope I
really think it's just another villain
in acting Moriarty as doomsday scenario
or enacting their own scenario using him
as a front a couple of other big
villains that it could be include
Moriarty's brother who's also named
James the real Colonel Moran Henry Peter
from Lady carfax story
Renee her own fan tomas and von borcke
but if it is in fact Moriarty here is
one possible reason why he's still alive
in Conan Doyle's story final solution we
find out that Moriarty's brother is
called James and the one true Moriarty
is called Professor Moriarty that would
mean that it was the brother who killed
himself on the rooftop and played the
Richard Brook role in Cannon Professor
Moriarty is someone who always acts
through agents it's a major character
trait that he never directly acts
against people especially Sherlock and
in Reichenbach fall and great game he
is very much up in Sherlock's face so
there's a chance that that was never the
real Moriarty take that evidence for
what you will but let me know in the
comments what is your biggest prediction
for series for a lot of people have been
asking me when it's going to air and
unless there's a major delay in
scheduling the actors it's basically
gonna be the same time next year they
already have their story for series four
and they're plotting out series 5 since
so many of you guys have been commenting
about how you want to you know Moriarty
lives video I might do that next week
I'm also going to be doing a series for
Q&A video you know that will be a
companion to this video so if you have
any special questions about series 4
that you want me to include in that just
write them in the comments this will
also be your entries for the giveaway -
I'll also be doing a new Doctor Who Q&A
as well as a Walking Dead video that'll
explain the giveaway I'm gonna be doing
whenever that show comes back - right
now click here for my breakdown of his
last vow and click here for the Q&A
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
[Music]